my pride strike that pose blue ivy
that's beyonce and jay-z's nine-year-old
daughter
modeling next to her mom for ivy park
tina knowles posted the video to her
instagram on wednesday
where she revealed it wasn't originally
planned for her granddaughter to be
featured
according to tina blue actually talked
her way into joining the photo shoot
captioning the video in part quote no
she was not supposed to be in it
she was just hanging out and got dressed
and i guess she said i'm not gonna tell
you what i could do
i'm gonna show you this makes me proud
we gotta respect the hustle blue's
grandma certainly did
adding quote i love that aggressive
spirit my blue blue
the moment also earned some fun
reactions in the comments
storm reed posted these heart eyes while
holly robinson pete went with the fire
emoji
blue ivy's can-do attitude follows a
standout year for her young
that was given career me in 2020 she had
several cameos in mom beyonce's movie
blackest king
she received her first bet award for her
song brown skin girl
and she was picked to narrate the
children's book hair love
and we've seen grandma tina sharing
other precious moments with blue
in january tina shared this video of her
granddaughter
tearing up the floor in dance class
[Music]
and get this she even remarked this is
blue but i
swear it looks like solange dancing at
this age
that month she also posted this selfie
to her instagram where blue
did her makeup tina joked in the caption
gonna save me a lot of money on these
makeup artist fees
and she's quite a makeup artist is she
yeah she's amazing
when e.t caught up with tina in 2019 she
praised her granddaughter's talents with
makeup
she put stones and does all this fancy
stuff she can do a
perfect cat eye i bought blue so many
makeup kits
much to her dad's dismay it's just for
playtime
okay we have fun